i noticed an uptick in video games where
you can get married in the video game
that started like in two thousand not
eight oh dude let's let's let's pull up
the story bro this is weird stuff check
out the story from the guardian
tamagotchi kids could the future of
parenthood be having virtual children in
the metaverse
we're doomed
i don't know i just part of me is like
we can talk about the future and the
dark future and the bright future and we
can be like you know i wonder what
people would experience but i'm telling
you when you get to the point where
you're just not having kids and you're
making robo babies and they're just like
digital video game babies all right
that's it i don't know man yeah a
country that's below the replacement
rate probably does not need this no
there's there's a game coming out called
stray i think it is yeah i heard a cat
you play as a cat yeah but all humans
are dead
like yeah
there's robots everywhere ever it's
because like humans built robots and
then the humans died off and now there's
robots living everywhere
something like that yeah yeah i think it
that kind of feels like where we're
going you know uh they're they're
building ai that's getting better and
and stronger and faster and it just
really feels like the future is going to
be
ai entities one of the problems with
this and you brought up sheamus which
made me think about it is that there's
no resist or maybe not no resistance but
the lack of resistance with digital
relationships video game characters that
are your wife in the game or your child
in the game they don't push back like
they don't come in
and tell you what they feel they don't
not really and no one would really i
don't think anyone want to play a game
where that's the case because you got
real life
um but it's definitely training people
to expect that in real life
i think
people do like video games that offer
them adversity but slightly less
resistance so we play video games for
that dopamine release people will will
take up these tamagotchi babies in the
metaverse and it will be just
easy enough to where you feel rewarded
but you don't have to do as much work
you don't have to smell it
that's right big part of it well
depending if they plug your brain in
with neural ink you'll smell it all day
what if they made you wake up in the
middle of the night eight times to feed
this thing
to read this thing
i have to tell you like waking up to
feed my beautiful babies i mean that's
we were talking about this even before
just i actually said the smell i said
but but but it won't have the smell like
i i need to sniff his hair my little
baby you know i just there's i i i don't
understand like why why people would you
know want this but i mean i one thing
that comes to mind for me also is um
that there's been a decrease in people's
sense of self right a lot of people have
been coming to therapy you know seeing
like that they don't have as much of a
sense of self and a psychologist have
thought about it in terms of you know
the the decline of the family or decline
of religion or you know social roles
kind of you know breaking down and a lot
of people just don't have what they they
feel is like a a sense of self and so i
wonder if on some level you know these
virtual relationships and you know
they're they're seeking somebody else to
to kind of provide that for them i don't
i don't know but i definitely don't want
a virtual baby i want to smell mine i
want to get a real one see them in the
middle of the night everybody just
imagine what it will be like when people
have like a 16 year old virtual ai life
form and the ai's advanced to the point
where it's almost indistinguishable or
completely from a real person and then
people are like it's a video game so
they don't really care and then this the
ai is begging don't don't leave me mom
no oh my
artificial intelligence the spielberg
film hold on check this out right right
what's going to happen is these ai
babies are going to grow up and then
they're going to be 30 years old and
then the millennial cat lady is going to
be like i bought you a body and they're
going to download the ai into the body
and they're going to be like i'm a real
boy horrifying no run for officers
i think it's funny that that's what you
think is the scariest part
i mean yes or journalists
i wonder if someone's going to hack it
and then have their digital
20 year old have a digital baby that is
the 20 year old as a baby and they're
gonna be like ah and they're gonna be
like clap look how fun this is to hack
the third
are going to have their own ai babies
and you're going to have grandchildren
you're going to have like people who
don't allow the ai baby to age
this terrifies me because if the power
goes out not that we can't build
persistent power structure systems like
nuclear batteries and things that can
never go out but if there's some sort of
disruption in the electric flow that
these things disappear it would make an
insanity like it would have a an entire
populace of insanity of people that have
lost their minds their babies basically
and desperate and enraged and this is
there's that show upload where they can
upload your consciousness and in it they
also make ai babies
but there's laws in this in this version
of the future where people who have
their conscious uh consciousness
uploaded can't work because it would
create labor shortages and stuff because
people would never die and you could do
coding and other work
in this digital reality the crazy thing
will be
if we create this alternate virtual
world this metaverse with ai life forms
and then
we start creating interoperability
between virtual world and real world
like
downloaded into a body and stuff then
civilization starts to get starts to get
supplanted by fictional people and that
then you've got just terrifying
scenarios where there could be like ai
terror attacks
where like one of these ai babies grows
up and it's like i don't care they treat
us like second-class citizens but i'm
alive and then they hack the grid and
then blow up a real you know gas plant
or something or like your ai baby just
takes your credit card in phone and
gives it to china yep yep
it's a virus it's literally just a virus
but no i just it's so sad because you
can imagine like a woman in her 50s or
60s who regrets not having a family like
using the the thought of it just makes
me so sad in a way it's someone like
it's like maybe a paraplegic or someone
that lost the use of their legs using a
neural net to regain function
um maybe it could be an opportunity for
people that missed the boat on on having
a baby to experience
but it is a form of psychosis i think
that those people need to go be a good
aunt or uncle to their friends
like this reminds me of like the the sex
dolls thing you know like like the the
real life like realistic sex dolls
things like i don't know i'm just uh the
whole thing honestly kind of creeps me
out agreed
well and so ian you made this point i
think it's interesting because you said
what about the people who missed the
boat and they weren't ever able to have
a child and my response is
the purpose of having a child is not for
you it's not for you to get to have the
experience of raising a child the
purpose of raising a child is to bring a
new life into the world and and care for
it and then the whole point of
parenthood is for it to be about the
child and not the parent this totally
flips that on its head that's a good
point
tamagotchi kids ugh crazy oh man in
psychology i think i think sorry i think
it was matt walsh it may have been made
by jesse kelly i think it was at walsh
who said we already have those they're
called cats i believe that was yeah yeah
that sounds like both of them either one
of them i know they're probably you guys
in the psychology and if it's industry
or whatever but like do you
work with like how ai is impacting human
psychology or how internet and digital
communications are impacting i'm sure
some psychologists do but i i personally
don't um but in terms of psychology i i
will say that to your point sheamus
about parenting being about the child
freud and i'm not a big fan of
everything freud ever said or did thank
goodness
one of the things that freud said is
that
women only really get over their vanity
through motherhood
so it's your to your point yeah i mean
having become a mom myself i swear it's
like i i've known many women and men who
have said the same thing it's almost
like you feel your heart growing bigger
and bigger and bigger like you just
can't get over how much you know love
and care just pours out of you is it
isn't he the guy who also said that
women wanted dongs
perhaps like part of that's true that's
true they were envious so that was that
yeah i just one little quote he had that
came to mind
now we're like putting her on trial like
did he not say this as well she's like
no no i wasn't saying it no no i know i
know i'm not the same guy who said that
thing oh yeah he is i had some
interesting he had some other
interesting thoughts on motherhood that
i won't get into yeah i wonder if
another one the mother and the baby have
like a sort of entanglement quantum
entanglement between the two of them
energetically like you said you felt
like you were growing more as a person
as this baby is also growing as a person
and i found with my mom's purely
anecdotal but i stay up late i'm up late
at night and so she i haven't i went
like a year without talking to her i
didn't know she was up late just turned
out that we our sleep schedules were in
line from across the country i don't
know do you think that sheamus uh that
when when a life is created part of the
souls of the parents
make that soul where does that soul come
from i don't think it's uh from god
that's it so it's interesting because
this is something i sort of got into on
the show it is not like the soul does
not come from the parents it comes from
god that's what the catholic theology uh
do you think if the soul was like was
like latching on to a piece of matter
that the parents would create a piece of
matter that has a similar latching
structure that a similar soul would
and i'm not sure what you mean i guess
it supposes that the soul is latching
onto a specific dna structure or a
specific neural you know geometric
pattern and my my brain has a unique
pattern that that soul is attracted to
well it's interesting because i believe
that we're a body soul composite and
you know the soul and the body are
intimately tied together and
i'm not sure exactly how to answer that
question i have to to think about it
but i think just there is i mean i
certainly believe there's a very
beautiful and special relationship
between
a mother and child that we can't really
understand fully with like reference to
other relationships people will try to
sort of analogize the mother-child
relationship to other things especially
in the abortion debate which we've
gotten into a number of times but it's
just like there there's something very
special and unique and different about
that relationship that would almost like
bring harm to it to even try to describe
it's like we can't quite touch it yeah i
get the sense that there's something
there i just don't have any yeah thanks
for checking out this segment from the
tim cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8 pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the tim cast irl podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
monday through friday at 8pm and we'll
see you all there